عند سفر وفي السفر ثقافه اعضاء الاكراميه
او البقشيش تختلف من بلد الى اخر ما يجعل
المساله محيره بل مرهقه احيانا كم مدفع
بالضبط
البلدان تحديدا
فنوبيا لا يقبل البقشيش بل انه يعتبر
اهانه مع ذلك لا يجب الافتراض بانه كل
البلدان في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ لا
تقبل البقشيش لانه امر معتاد مثلا في
الهند اما في اوروبا يختلف ايضا من منطقه
الى اخرى بين الالزامي والشائع ولكن ما
مقدار البقشيش الذي يتوجب علينا تقديمه
وايضا نسال متى نقدم واين لميس ابراهيم
راح تعرفنا اكثر على ما هو المتوقع حول
الثقافه البقشيش او الاكراميه بشكل عام في
الوجهات السياحيه الشهيره
وكم راح ندفع متى انتبهوا بس تروحوا على
امريكا وما تدفعوا بقشيش ورطه لا ادري
والله نجربها
لكل بلد ثقفته ونظرته الخاصه للبقشيش ورغم
ان الاختلافات طفيفه الا انها قد تشكل
مساله حساسه في اسيا يجب عليك في البدايه
تحديد ما اذا كان يجب عليك تقديم البقشيش
على الاطلاق اما في اوروبا اعطاء البقشيش
لا يعد شائعا في اسبانيا وفي ايطاليا
عموما رسوم الخدمه عاده ما تضاف الى
فواتير الفنادق والمطاعم وفي بريطانيا
يعتبر البقشيش معتادا في حال كنت راضيا عن
الخدمه وفي فرنسا الاكراميه ليست الزاميه
لكنها بمثابه مفاجاه ساره في امريكا اي
خدمه تقريبا تعد قابله للبقشيش وفي اجزاء
كثيره من الولايات المتحده اصبحت نسبه 20%
اكراميه مالوفه الى حد ما اما كندا فتقع
ما بين اوروبا والولايات المتحده من حيث
ثقافه البقشيش يعني دفع بقشيش بنسبه 15%
للخدمه الجيده في المطاعم وفي المكسيك
الاكراميه ليست الزاميه لكنها متوقعه
على العموم سال الناس في السعوديه والعراق
برايك ما هي قيمه الاكراميه التي يجب
دفعها نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
هو اصلا المفروض ما يكون في اكراميه لان
هذا عمله واجبه يسوي الشهاده ياخذ عليه
راتب فما في كل واحد يسوي عمل انا ادفع
الفلوس وادفع الاكراميه فاعتقد اذا انا
مضطر ما تعدل الخمسه في المئه عشره في
المئه بالكثير يعني في احيانا قليله ممكن
ما يعطيك
عشره
مقرون بامرين الخدمه قديش كويسه وقديش
الفاتوره كبيره يمكن عشره او 15% من قيمه
الفاتوره مثلا بحدود العشره ريال الى
العشرين على حسب الخدمه المقدمه
هي تحدد الاكراميه يعني بحيث اذا كانت
برضو حتى الخدمه سيئه مستحيل بتاخذ
اكراميه عليها والله انا ما لها سقف محدد
على حسب الاستطاعه في حينه يعني انا مع
الاكراميه
اذا سواء اوتيل او مطعم
حلوه يعني
وتشجع العامل او الموظف على انه يعطي
زياده
[موسيقى]
سمر المشطه زميلتنا صحفيه في قسم الاقتصاد
تنضم الينا
ندفع ما ندفع زين انا اتكلم ما بها اتكلم
اولا ندفع ولا ما ندفع انا يعني مثلا طالب
اشتغلت في هذا المكان شلون اخليك تدفعين
اكثر وانت وانت مبسوطه طيب سؤال جميل هناك
يعني البارحه شفت شويه قواعد او شروط او
نقول ممكن
تحصل عليها في اذا كنت تشتغل سواء في
المطعم او سواء مثلا في صالون او الى اخره
اول شيء طبعا اهم شيء الابتسامه العريضه
الابتسامه العريضه ممكن تزيد التب مالتك
اب تو فايف برسنت اكثر بعدين في شغله
ثانيه اللي هي تعرف عن نفسك اول ما توصل
الى الطاوله تقول انا فلان الفلاني اليوم
انا الويتر تبعكم او انا اليوم المساعد
تبعكم انت شنو انك تتعرف على اسم المقابل
اله وبعدين يقول لك سيد عادل سيده راويه
يعني يتكلم باسمك بعدين اعطاء
شلون يعني
الاطراء يزيد ممكن بعشره بالمئه بس طبعا
لازم نكون حذرين يعني مو غزل او شيء يكون
مثلا انت اختاريت شيء معين
بالمجيده او انت تعرف تختار فعلا الطعام
او مثلا سترتك حلوه يعني انه انت اطراء
بسيط بس يكون جدا محتشم وضمن الحدود هذا
ممكن يزيد التب عندك عشره بالمئه
وعلى ما يبدو بانه في كتير ناس بيستجيبوا
لهذا الموضوع لانه حتى اشواق عماله بتقول
انه هي بتوقع في هذا الموضوع وبتحس انه
لازم تدفع تعطي بقشيش اكثر كل ما كانت
الخدمه احسن
لميس اعطتنا فكره على مثلا بامريكا او
باوروبا
كيف البقشيش وقديه نسبته عاده من الفاتوره
عنا بالعالم العربي هل الموضوع مشابه ام
انه يعني هذا بيرجع للشخص نفسه قديش بحب
يعطي اليوم في شي اسمه او مصطلح جديد طلع
اسمه
يعني تضخم في التبن تضخم داخل علينا في كل
المجالات طبعا يعني اسالك انت اليوم مثلا
انا اليوم استحي الصراحه انطي عشره درهم
يعني
للصالون او في المطعم يعني صارت يعني عشره
احسبها على اساس اول شيء عندك الفاتوره
مثلا المتعارف عليه في الدول العربيه 10
الى 15% بالمطاعم الفاخره اوكي بالمطاعم
الفاخره بالمطاعم اللي اقل يعني ممكن خمسه
بالمئه اذا كان مطعم يعني بسيط كاجوال مو
مطعم فاخر بس بالمطاعم الفاخره المفروض
تترك 10 الى 15 في المئه من الفاتوره في
المناطق العربيه بس عندك في منا طق اخرى
مثلا اسيا تعتبر اهانه انه تعيفين تب
فلازم انت قبل ما تروح لهذا الدوله تعرف
البروتوكول انه هل تعطيه تب او لا تعطيه
تب لا ننسى انه في امريكا مثلا ما قلنا
المينيموم ويج او الاجور جدا قليله يعني
ممكن تكون الساعه
على البقشيش ممكن الى عشر دولارات بالساعه
اذا قسموها فيعني يعتمد يعني حياته تعتمد
على هذا البقشيش في بعض الدول احنا وقت
انتهى استمتعت باللقاء طبعا دائما دائما
[موسيقى]
يتعب صحيح من الصبح لليل او من الصبح
للعصر يتعبى
المطعم اكيد هي القناه انا مثلا اريد
انطيه او ما انطيه فحسب يعني انسانيتي انا
وياه نشيل المبلغ ما ادري وننطيه له يعني
تشوفه قدامك شخص فقير يعني
[موسيقى]
حسب نوع المكان وحسب الشكل العامل مرات
تشوفه تنقهر عليه يعني
مو مفروضه مو شي المفروض على الزبون بس
مرات من اللي انا اعتبرها من اللياقه
انتقم العامل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات